y
[Música]
el presidente de eeuu joe biden llegó a
arabia saudita y se reunió con el
príncipe heredero mohamed bin salman en
una polémica parada de su gira por medio
oriente el mandatario norteamericano
dice que hizo al monarca responsable del
asesinato del periodista llamado yogui
en esta emisión analizamos este viaje de
bailén y los nexos económicos de eeuu
con los sauditas
europa es golpeada de lleno por una
intensa ola de calor más de 300 personas
han perdido la vida en españa y portugal
en la última semana como consecuencia de
las altas temperaturas mientras que los
bomberos intentan controlar las llamas
en varias naciones el reino unido- de
metió por primera vez en la historia la
alerta roja por el calor extremo lo que
implica riesgo para la vida
en sí de la ncaa del primer ministro ran
y la wii kremen xix asumió como
presidente interino después de que el
parlamento aceptará la dimisión del ya
antiguo mandatario gotabaya rajapaksa
quien voló a singapur en medio de una
fuerte movilización social el
legislativo tiene previsto comenzar este
sábado con la designación de un nuevo
líder
momento de actualizar las noticias en la
pantalla de france 24 gracias por
continuar con nosotros yo soy juan
rubiales comenzamos en arabia saudita
porque el presidente de eeuu joe biden
llegó hoy a yeda y se reunió con el
príncipe heredero mohamed bin salman
maiden aseguró que a ver le aseguró
haberle recriminado al monarca el
asesinato del periodista yamaha jog y
quien murió en el consulado saudita en
estambul en octubre de 2018 según el
mandatario norteamericano y su
responsable a bin salman de este crimen
que según la inteligencia de washington
recibió la aprobación del príncipe
escuchamos a bailén investigó dice
básicamente dijo que no era
personalmente responsable de ello
indique que pensaba que lo era y
dijo que no era personalmente
responsable de ellos y que tomó medidas
contra los responsables
y luego pasé a hablar más acerca de cómo
tratar con cualquier oposición a la
crítica de la administración saudí y
otros países
fue visto para mí como una violación de
los derechos humanos
mucha polémica ha generado esta visita
del presidente de byd en arabia saudita
porque durante su campaña el mandatario
hizo un llamado a aislar al reyno por el
crimen de hawking para analizar el tema
nos acompaña desde la ciudad de bogotá
rafael piñero es profesor de relaciones
internacionales en la universidad
externado de colombia señor piñeros
gracias por estar con nosotros joe biden
dijo hoy que no se arrepiente de haber
hecho su llamado a que el mundo apartara
a la de sauditas pero hoy saludó al
príncipe salman y se reunió con él no
está evidenciando un doble discurso
las necesidades de los eeuu llevan a que
lo que sucede en 2020 durante la campaña
presidencial no sea fácil de mantener en
el 2022 siendo presidente de los eeuu
incluso previo a la elección se sabía
que esa posición roja impuesta por el
entonces candidato yo bailé me va a ser
difícil de mantener en el tiempo la
situación en ucrania el precio del
petróleo la influencia creciente de
rusia y de china en la región la
necesidad de desarrollar ciencia
tecnología innovación redes de 5g en la
región han llevado a que si hubo algún
ha estado suministrada que tomar un
enfoque distinto los países árabes y
arabia saudita en particular no ha sido
tan vehemente como esperaba a eeuu en
condenar el ataque ruso a ucrania esa
razón yo creo que es la principal para
adoptar un enfoque más pragmático si se
quiere en la relación entre eeuu y
arabia saudita
hay una serie de
convenios de acuerdos firmados entre los
dos y cambiar completamente el curso que
planteó el ex presidente de un ancho
alrededor de venta de armas y de bienes
y servicios es muy complicado
ahora bien el petróleo sigue siendo un
elemento importante y algunos otros
elementos que se buscaron impulsar
durante esta visita para seguir
influyendo por parte de eeuu en la
política de medio oriente y
especialmente nada de zorita que efecto
creo que va a tener a nivel interno esta
visita para joe biden ya está recibiendo
críticas por parte de miembros de su
propio partido
es problemático lo que usted menciona
porque sin duda alguna el entorno a
nivel interno en los eeuu no es fácil
para el presidente yo voy de la
inflación es un elemento
significativamente importante que si me
perturban la mente de los hogares
estadounidenses pero también la
debilidad en términos de proteger los
derechos fundamentales que han sido
reconocidos por el histórico fallo de la
corte suprema los eeuu alrededor del
aborto la plantea un elemento muy
complicado al interior de las voces más
liberales y de izquierda de su partido y
es howard y no tiene la intención de
defender los derechos humanos con amigos
y sin duda alguna las críticas en este
sentido se van a dirigir a eso es que si
bien como candidato voy a plantear una
una línea excesivamente rígida y roja y
hoy vemos que el pragmatismo y las
necesidades puntuales derivadas de
elementos coyunturales han hecho que los
derechos humanos queden en un segundo
lugar y si yo creo que va a ser la línea
que no necesariamente le conviene y el
otro problema grave es que en el segundo
en el segundo semestre no se van a poder
solucionar los graves problemas
económicos y sociales que aquejan a la
población estadounidense por lo tanto
esta visita y en particular su reunión
con movimiento y salman no
necesariamente va a ser muy positiva por
los intereses propios y del partido de
cara a noviembre volviendo al tema
económico bailén dice que él va a arabia
saudita por petróleo este sábado él
participa en la cumbre del consejo de la
cooperación del golfo creo que sé que se
va a lograr ese objetivo y tendría este
aumento un impacto concreto en la
situación económica mundial
los factores de inestabilidad pasan por
elementos que van más allá e
instintivamente el precio del cruz es un
factor importante pero recordemos que
hoy la situación en mente el continente
de hecho la situación macroeconómica y
monetaria en la cual un euro se cotiza
igual que un dólar no genera un elemento
de certidumbres necesario hoy en el
continente y también euro pero hay
crisis en italia
asimismo la crisis derivada de
fertilizantes y demás hace que sea muy
difícil por lo tanto veo complejo el
acuerdo que alcancen sea suficiente para
detener el alza inflacionista a nivel
mundial particularmente en eeuu gracias
a rafael piñero es por este análisis en
france24 seguimos eso sí con ese tema
porque previamente a su llegada a arabia
saudita el presidente joe biden se
reunió en belén para verse con mohammed
abbas presidente de la autoridad
nacional palestina el líder de la casa
blanca defendió el plan de una solución
con dos estados una consigna plasmada
por primera vez en los acuerdos de oslo
de 1993 sin embargo hayden reconoció que
esa se muestra muy lejana en este
momento por su parte abbas e hizo un
llamado a washington para que colabore
con los territorios palestinos y aseguró
querer tender una mano a israel para
lograr la paz
esperamos con ansia los pasos de la
administración de eeuu para fortalecer
las relaciones bilaterales al reabrir el
consulado de eeuu en jerusalén este
eliminar la organización para la
liberación de palestina de la lista de
terroristas de eeuu no somos terroristas
y reabrir su oficina en washington y por
nuestra parte estamos dispuestos a
trabajar en el marco de la asociación y
la cooperación con el fin de eliminar
cualquier obstáculo para lograrlo
europa sufre una grave ola de calor con
nuevos récords de temperaturas
superiores a los 40 grados celsius pero
además desde francia hasta grecia varios
países del viejo continente están
padeciendo múltiples incendios
forestales que han obligado a evacuar a
miles de personas de sus hogares otros
como italia y reino unido- se preparan
para afrontar el pico de calor extremo
en pleno verano unas temperaturas y
desastres ambientales agravados por la
crisis climática mundial que ha elevado
la temperatura de la tierra marina
sardenya tiene los detalles
el sur de europa en llamas y marcando
récords de altas temperaturas que
superan los 40 grados celsius la
península ibérica' está sufriendo las
condiciones más secas de los últimos
1.000 años según la o m/m una ola de
calor que deja más de 300 muertos en
españa y portugal donde los bomberos
luchan contra múltiples incendios de
gran magnitud al terminar un día la alta
temperatura no es la única consecuencia
adversa de las olas de calor la
atmósfera estable y estancada actúa como
una tapa que atrapa los contaminantes
atmosféricos incluidas las partículas
aumentando su concentración más cerca de
la superficie el resultado es la
degradación de la calidad del aire y los
efectos adversos para la salud
especialmente para las personas
vulnerables tipo las bocanadas de aire
caliente y las llamas se extienden desde
el norte de áfrica hasta italia grecia o
reino unido que este viernes emitió la
alerta roja en el centro de la isla por
calor extremo la oficina de meteorología
advirtió que se podría superar los 40
grados también en francia miles de
personas han sido evacuadas de sus
hogares a medida que los incendios
forestales arrasan las regiones del
sureste del país
a excepción del pasado estamos viviendo
una temporada única en términos de
dificultad ya hemos visto el triple de
bosques quemadores en comparación con
2020 hemos tenido tanto una primavera
muy seca como incendios que han
comenzado con fuerza como las de player
default la deshidratación golpes de
calor y problemas respiratorios por la
degradación del aire debido al humo y
otras partículas sostenidas en la
atmósfera afectan a la salud de millones
de europeos y es que miles de hectáreas
arden cada verano en europa una
problemática agravada con el
calentamiento global pero también los
activistas denuncian que existe un lobby
de los incendios empresas que cobran por
apagar fuegos con fuertes intereses
económicos urbanísticos y a veces
enfocados en la venta de madera el
primer ministro ramiro y crema exige
juramento como presidente interino del
tri lanka este alto funcionario sucede
hacia gotabaya rajapaksa quien abandonó
el país el martes rumbo a singapur en
medio de una gran agitación social y una
fuerte crisis económica el parlamento
que aceptó la renuncia a vía email de
rajapaksa debe ahora comenzar a elegir a
uno de terminar el resto del mandato nos
lo cuenta juan pabló lucumí
escenas de gozo en la capital decir
blanca en las calles de colombo cientos
de personas celebraron la división del
presidente gotabaya rajapaksa
bueno hay un espíritu festivo en este
momento creo que la gente aquí está muy
contenta con esta decisión
una salida confirmada del viernes por la
mañana por el parlamento de es blanca la
carta de dimisión del presidente
rajapaksa enviada por correo electrónico
tras su llegada a singapur ha sido
validada
he recibido la dimisión del presidente
gotabaya rajapaksa de acuerdo con el
artículo 38 1 de la constitución de la
república socialista democrática decir
lanka en consecuencia el presidente ha
renunciado legalmente a la presidencia
la asume y libia
el primer ministro rajiv y crime single
es ahora el presidente en funciones
según la constitución el parlamento
tiene 30 días para nombrar a su sucesor
los diputados lo elegirán en los
próximos siete días
el tiempo se acaba sri lanka atraviesa
actualmente una grave crisis económica
la isla se enfrenta a cortes de
electricidad escasez de combustible
escasez de alimentos y una inflación
récord para salir de la crisis una
solución desbloquear las negociaciones
con el fondo monetario internacional y
obtener un plan de rescate
vamos con noticias de la guerra en
ucrania porque un nuevo ataque ruso en
la ciudad de ny pro dejó al menos tres
muertos y 15 heridos los misiles
golpearon una planta industrial y una
calle cercana según el gobernador
regional entretanto el presidente
ucraniano por lo diversa el skip pidió
reconocer a rusia como estado terrorista
tras el ataque del jueves contra la
ciudad de benítez ya un bombardeo que
dejó 23 personas muertas selene es que
agregó que existe la necesidad urgente
de crear un tribunal especial sobre la
agresión rusa a su país mosco por su
parte se defiende alegando que el ataque
estaba dirigido a un edificio en el que
altos cargos de las fuerzas armadas de
ucrania se reunían con proveedores de
armas extranjeros
las fuerzas armadas de la federación
rusa continúan su operación militar
especial en ucrania misiles calibre de
alta precisión con base en el mar
alcanzaron un edificio en la guarnición
de la casa de oficiales una ciudad de
milicia en el momento del ataque se
estaba celebrando en esta instalación
militar una reunión entre el mando de
las fuerzas aéreas de ucrania y los
representantes de los proveedores
extranjeros
vamos a mexico para reportar la
detención de rafael caro quintero uno de
los líderes más importantes del
narcotráfico en ese país y quien lideró
al desaparecido cártel de guadalajara
una de las organizaciones de este tipo
más poderosas en los años 80 autoridades
mexicanas confirmaron el arresto de
quintero de 69 años quienes se han
recordado sobre todo por el asesinato y
tortura del agente de la dea enrique
kiki camarena en 1985 pasó 28 años en la
cárcel pero fue liberado por un
tecnicismo legal y a la hora de su
recaptura quintero ya se había fugado
era uno de los diez prófugos más
perseguidos del mundo y sobre él pesaba
una recompensa de 20 millones de dólares
en eeuu la cámara de representantes votó
este viernes a favor de restablecer el
derecho al aborto en el país luego de la
decisión del tribunal supremo de derogar
el histórico fallo de roe versus wake
este de fallo que aseguraba el derecho a
la interrupción del embarazo a nivel
federal este nuevo proyecto fue aprobado
por los representantes demócratas sin
embargo tiene pocas posibilidades de
convertirse en ley ya que no cuenta con
la mayoría necesaria en el senado en
donde demócratas y republicanos se
dividen los escaños al 50%
así terminamos esta emisión informativa
la pantalla de france 24 pero la
información continúa aquí también en
france 24 punto com
[Música]